today since you're the 2 o'clock class
slightly less bad than the 1 o'clock
class slightly we're going to talk about
Queen sacrifices now as you all know I
always sacrifice my queen sometimes
intentionally right okay actually I
never do that but I did it twice last
week so my quota for like 10 years is up
so when I play you today I'm not going
to sacrifice my queen and when I say
play you I mean leave the room and go
watch Miami versus Toronto nothing
you guys did Homer II know what happened
in the game no I'm kidding we do too
because you know Toronto all right so
there's a team with one good player
versus the team with no good players
what he thinks going to win
the one good player right yeah so
Miami's going to win and it's see I told
you at home even before the game start
it's pretty good alright so this was a
game I played a chord Sachs in a game 15
tournament that meant that means each
guy gets 15 minutes was there a delay or
an increment no because Mike comer was
the director how and he rules with an
iron fist that's where my hand hurts so
this game was played last week I had the
white pieces is it recording amazing ok
and my opponent play d5 boo ok and I
played Bishop c4 I thought I did I still
can't ok and you'll notice I have a
leading development because unlike you I
get all my pieces out in castle and you
guys like stare at the ceiling oh wow
there's lights Wow
they paid the electric bill when they
don't actually ok so so my opponent said
that's enough developing pieces and he
played here ok and then we got this
position and well he played a very risky
move and if my comer was here he would
be furious
not because of
he's just always furious and he played
nine gf6 and when these three pieces are
here in every my comer lecture ever what
should white do and I played this move
because my comer was there he was the
director so if I didn't he would forfeit
me you with the right answer now
14:40 the people at home were like
fourteen forty but the kids know it's
going on see all right
so I played 95 Rahr Rahr
okay and now he resigned okay next game
so how did he stop me from taking on f7
the answer he held both of my arms down
okay and then I use my nose and I went
ah okay
anyone anyone Bueller how did he stop
Knight f7 Bishop f7 out you he could
play Queen e7 but I would still take on
f7 because my minor pieces are worth
less than his Queen you with the right
answer d5 now taking on f7 risky I took
on d5
now he developed his bishop and now he's
going to castle now when you castle and
your opponent doesn't castle
you should stop them from castling so
that's what I did I took on e5 and he
was like man if I Castle then Ben's
going to win one of my pieces so he took
and now I put him in check now if you
were here for the one o'clock class I
kept trying to cast Lee illegally the
computer wouldn't let me but then over
there about ten minutes later one of the
players tried to castle illegally
remember what I'm talking about it was
your opponent so yeah okay so you can't
castle when you're in check even in the
one o'clock class they try but trying is
the first step to failure so I think
they should play this Knight to d7 but
my opponent played this Knight to d7
okay and I attacked his Knight so he
still can't castle we could buy twin is
Knight okay well that's the drunken
that's there we go okay then the night
went here and I put him in check
man this guy's having a tough time
cancelling isn't he
okay so again he blocked and I said oh
well you'd like to castle here you go
castle into that now if he castles
checkmate gives white the advantage
right
on the other hand if he doesn't Castle
this checkmate gives me the advantage so
what did he do who he played g6 okay and
remember I sacrificed my queen this
lecture so I played here no I didn't
sacrifice my queen yet I play Queen h6
and now he tried to castle now I'm going
to tell you a funny story pay attention
it's a true story based on a true story
as Aviv would say if you are playing in
the chess tournament and your opponent
was black and you were white and your
opponent illegally castled here what
would you do raise your hand let's see
Martin no you incorrect you incorrect
Arjen that's correct
ours is the only one who could possibly
get the right answer now I have a son
although I have no son and my son was
a-ok when my son was a little kid couple
days ago okay when when my son was a
little kid if his opponent did something
against the rules he was like hey you
can do there and I was like if you let
them do that you could have taken like
seven pieces and he's like but they
can't do that and I'm like why don't you
let them do that and take all their
pieces so they give you an example your
opponent touches a piece and it's going
to like the best move ever and you're
like no then he puts it back and
illegally moves up he said loses all of
his pieces
hey hey you touched that first place
make that move that beats me
that's what you kids all do if your
opponent castles illegally
you could play Queen takes h7 to me so
that's what our G would we be like yeah
castle me okay I'm not sure that's a
ethical but you know who's a kid's Clark
okay
my opponent decided to take my bishop
okay and I was like you can have my
bishop and I'm going to check meet you
he didn't want to get checkmated so what
did he do he did he did not resign well
what if he castles then I would play 96
mate d'argent did they get it no do you
get it yeah
okay so my opponent playing Rick FA
because you kids suggested it okay
hey you left your you know your
membership card show your card and save
okay
now I played Knight takes pawn that has
two threats one you see and one you
don't see I'm just kidding you don't see
either one Arjun okay
Knight f6 is me because I said so and
shocking Arjun to no end Queen takes
rook is also made now the class is like
whoa that's that's like the three
o'clock class there right Lou none of
this Lou I mean Joey that's like that's
what I said can I help you
you mean you mean the night that can't
move because the bishop spinning it yeah
so if black plays rook a7 that's me and
I can't take it won't let me also that's
me and the reason they're both me is the
bishop is pinning the night so eat honey
honey
he unpinned his night with which move
bond takes bishop now none of those
moves are made this or this now if your
opponent is rated 2500 points higher
than you Lulu
um and they give their Queen away are
they the crazy one or are you the crazy
one in this instance it's both but you
know you're not supposed to know that
okay so I gave my queen away because
this is the Queen sacrifice class Arjun
quick Queen takes FA is this isn't the 3
o'clock class slow ok now my opponent
should have been hmm why is my 2682
opponent giving his queen away instead
he was slobbering all over himself
taking my queen you know Tarzan he
didn't know where he was in the jungle
because it was cortex he's like where am
i and he works in the building and he
still didn't know where he was ok right
Bensimon yeah see you don't even know
we're in fog and he should have fought
mean why did Grandmaster fine go give
his Queen away instead he went
yum yum yum yum yum which is the only
legal move yeah and then I played me
because his Knights not here defending
it anymore and before the 1 o'clock
class certain players named Martin said
what's removing the guard I don't know
what it is that's what it is so his
knight is defending f6 and then when I
go here his Knights not defending f6 and
then me and when I met him he's like oh
I didn't see that and I'm like you
thought I gave my Queen away and he's
like yeah
all right so I did give my queen away
and my bishop but me just worth more as
opposed to what this guy stood in the
tournament once okay so I won hooray
and then I got my prize now that was
round one okay now your favorite chess
teacher Danny Machuca who teach who does
Danny Machuca teach here you what you so
you're ready has been the same for 12
years and you're only seven Wow okay so
yeah I know then your reading isn't the
same for 12 years it's all a joke this
is my game when Machuca we played a
practice game what did we practice I
practice taking his pieces and he
practice getting checkmated we did we
did great wow we were really in fire
yeah I think he did even better than I
did
right right jelly what yeah and all the
dislike I don't understand the jokes
okay so I played the closed Benoni it's
all closed he could take on pissant but
you kids don't know the Opera song rule
so he didn't do it
you guys just don't know what you don't
know know what I mean
okay so so this stuff happened I've had
whiten this I've got black in this
position many times okay now I wanted to
play Knight here in the one o'clock
class I would just do it because they
would say like yeah okay that's pretty
close but then in real life we have to
actually make legal moves okay and then
I got the air and now he was like I
can't move this spawn I can't move this
spawn I can't move this spawn so he
decided to move this pawn unfortunately
his knights and the Weiss he would just
night out of the way
okay now I decided I would checkmate my
opponent because I went to the internet
and I wrote how do you win it chess and
it said checkmate your opponent and I
all right so I played h5 putting it in H
R R then the H file will be open and my
other rook will come over it's funny
because I did that okay
and he played the move he wanted to play
and now we played Barney chess a one two
three I take you you take me you're the
worst singers in history so so that's
what we did everybody took everybody and
now when I played h5 you were all
laughing at me but now I play Knight g4
now my pawn is protecting my knight yay
and my knight can go in the center and
my Bishop can move and his rook is all
silly okay so now this was a very funny
part of the game my opponent went mmm
and played Rick f1 and with his hand
still on his rook he put his rook back
on f4 he was like wait rook f1 that
walks into a fork in real life and in
chess you should never walk into a fork
so what move can black makes that Forks
whites pieces 93 for King the Queen and
rook that's nothing to sneeze it that
wins the queen or a ruck okay so my
opponents like wait a minute
Rick f1 that's no good so he played rook
f3 and I played Bishop f6 I'm going to
put him in check so the kids in the
class are happy and my comer manly when
you put somebody in check my comers
really happy okay so I put him in check
I wonder how you got Shaq hold on no I
guess he blocked with the corner
blocking with the Queen is silly what
did he do he played king each one and I
went rawr
now I think I should play Knight H - but
I haven't analyzed it with a computer
but I play Queen h4 threatening check me
I could have but I didn't see it how
could I have just checkmated him yeah
that's what I thought yeah okay that's
it back to the real world yeah it's a
five step okay yeah and one of the steps
is to apologize the people that you
wronged oh that's another kind of stuff
okay so Queen h4 you learned that stuff
later all right
now Queen h4 threatens me he's dating
Machuca he played a four and I made it
him no way that didn't happen alright so
I thought he would play h3 but he played
g3 is this meat what would the one
o'clock class say no they would say
what's check me is that check me no
because he takes it ok so I so I
retreated I know when my queen is
attacked and I move my Queen to e7 and
Heaphy and cat on his night-night g2 and
I attacked his rock and he's like I and
now my rook and his King are going to
have a meeting okay
and after the after the meeting meeting
adjourned so after Rick f1 I play g5 and
he's like you're not going to meet me
and he attacked on the queenside
and I said I'm going to meet you and he
was like wow that Bishop is good and I
said you can't talk during the game and
he's like oh sorry and he took my bishop
and I took his Knight and he took my
pawn and I was like old boy I'm almost
at your king but this Knights a good
defender so I attacked his Knight and I
said I'm going to take your knight and
then are and then he called the director
and said I was talking okay so he
attacked a pawn by discovered attack by
Bishop e2 stopping my knight from coming
in and now his Queens attacking my pawn
and now we Barney chest it up again we
had a good reason though Dani Machuca
looks like Barney the Dinosaur
right you know what I mean you like
think oh yeah that's right
right Bensimon yeah okay so I took his
Knight
I took his pawn and he took my pawn now
most of you when getting your rook over
here would move your king out of the way
that's because you're not grandmasters I
just played rook over here then he said
you can't do that I saw him a grandma
she's like all I apologize okay now if I
Castle he'll take my pawn on a seven
right now man yum yum so I play King to
d7 now I was hoping he would do that but
that's war one o'clock class and now I'm
going to go here and then I'm going to
do that stuff I said I was going to do
so he attacked on the Queen side I
attacked on the Kings side he attacked
on the Queen side and I ran away and now
I can castle over here yeah the one
o'clock class said so they said okay
so my king is going to run away and then
I'm going to check meet him and now he
should play Queen takes pawn I think but
he played pawn takes pawn and I played
Shak and he moved out a check to take my
rook it's pretend then I took this now
let's see who's good at counting what's
the material situation who's ahead for
those of you at home the most common
answer was me that they're ahead about
equal you with the right answer equal we
both have a queen we both have a king we
both have two rooks we both have four
pawns both have a minor piece now black
is threatening yum-yum-yum right
a free bishop so he moved his bishop
make sense okay and now I played the
greatest combination ever it was number
three at the restaurantt combination
three vegetarian you understand Lulu
because number three okay so I checked
him and shockingly he moved his King and
then I checked him again now if his King
moves up he's not protecting his rook
very much also his King is moving up but
he should have moved his King up because
he thought he move into safety he went
here and he thought he would castle soon
right that's there's nothing wrong with
that okay now I did my patented Queen
sacrifice you can't do it because I
patented it yeah that's better than the
move that I made that's not a Queen
sacrifice because my rooks defending my
Queen before why
but what it is checks I was it before
check all I know like the game was
played to 2200 years ago so it was
before check ok Joey yeah I agree
before what also I have a question who's
Joey who's on first huh hi so the right
answer has been said several times so I
played queen bee for Chuck notice how
it's check notice how it attacks is
queen now what's funny is White has more
than one legal move who can count that
high how many legal moves is white have
very difficult question you three you
could go here here and here those are
the three ways out of check whichever a
move you make I make the same move yeah
well some kind of check if you take then
that's then that's me and if you play
Queen C 3 then that's me and if you play
Queen D 2 then that's me
although Queen takes Queen is also made
but that's sort of cuter 93 so actually
it was a Pyrrhic victory because he was
already set up for the next game I had
to get all these pieces back to the
original squares okay and then I got
really sick as it was so hard so I did
go take a nap right and then I wrote a
book after I woke up called sleep like a
grandmaster okay and then my opponent
wrote a book get checkmated like an a
player ok that's sold more copies that
is very common book yeah you agree Joey
yeah see you actually alright
right and then after I play Queen before
check what did Danny Machuca say
uhh whoo that was a good answer that was
the best answer my opponent who was a
good internal okay
he said class dismissed
all right now go play chess